ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant les sénateurs vont
reprendre la discussion du collectif
budgétaire après le couac et de ce matin
qui a vu le rejet surprise de l'article
concernant le durcissement des droits de
succession tout de suite donc une
direction à l'hémicycle pour la suite de
l'examen de ce texte bonne après midi
est la séance et reprises
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale de finances pour 2012
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement 207
rectifié quater tendant inséré un
article additionnel après l'article 8
c'est monsieur assouline qui le défend
le 207 rectifié quater
oui monsieur le président je ministre je
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues je veux faire pour justifier
cet amendement un tout petit rappel
quand le gouvernement de lionel jospin
avait décidé de d'impulser la tnt
il s'agissait de remplir deux objectifs
dans l'offre audiovisuelle le pluralisme
augmenter l'offre de chaînes et de
possibilités donc le pluralisme et la
deuxième vertu était de faire que des
nouveaux entrants dans un paysage
relativement concentré fermé alors
puissent émettre ses objectifs après
quelques doutes sur à l'époque si on se
replonge dix ans après il y avait eu des
doutes sur le succès et bien le succès a
été au rendez vous et les français
étaient les spectateurs ont apprécié le
fait que l'on passe à plus de 20 chaînes
nouvelles qui se sont déployés dans
notre paysage audiovisuel or eux depuis
nous assistons des fois à quelques
transgression de l'objectif initial
il peut y avoir à linverse de l'esprit
de pluralisme et de diversité des
mouvements de concentration nouveau
voire même des tentations de
valorisation financière de ce qui a été
acquis pour zéro euro puisqu'il s'agit
du domaine public en l'état cède 7
fréquences à tel ou un tel
c'est gratuitement et l'on assiste à des
tentations aussi donc de valorisation
financière de spéculation calmes on dit
simplement sur ce domaine public alors
l'amendement que je vous présente n'est
pas une nouvelle invention puisqu'il a
été adopté par notre assemblée dans le
projet de loi
budgétaire initial 2012
l'année dernière il a été adopté ensuite
par l'assemblée nationale le
gouvernement lui même avait trouvé que
l'objet de cet amendement était allé
dans le bon sens puisque le csa lui même
s'était émue de ces dérives et le cs a
même cherché un des moyens presque
réglementaire d'interdiction de telles
possibilités mais nous allons voir ce
genre de préconisations du csa va
certainement aller devant le juge parce
que ici et là c'est contestée alors
l'amendement que je propose est assez
modérée et permet vertus que tout
gouvernement peut apprécier mais aussi
ceux qui sont charge de responsabilités
pour pour le bien de la nation
l'ensemble de ce parlement et de notre
assemblée d'obtenir des recettes
supplémentaires pour le budget d'état à
moment donné où les difficultés montre
que c'est toujours nécessaire d'aller
chercher des nouvelles recettes
possibles
alors voilà qu'est ce qui s'est passé si
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat ont
voté pour la dernière fois et le
gouvernement était plutôt favorable à
l'esprit est bien le gouvernement avait
à l'assemblée modifier mon écriture
notre écriture pensant qu'il s'était une
écriture plus constitutionnel endroit
bien malheureusement le conseil
constitutionnel a cassé cette décision
en disant que l'écriture de l'assemblée
nationale n'était pas constitutionnelle
et que celle que nous avions ce au sénat
était était plus valable alors avec
toute cette expérience est
enrichissement et bien on a écrit un
amendement qui préserve ce sur quoi nous
étions tous d'accord mais qui répond et
aux attentes du conseil constitutionnel
et aussi de tous les acteurs qui se sont
penchés et il y en a beaucoup
depuis quelques jours sur cet amendement
pour qu'il n'ait aucun effet pervers qui
soit le plus juste possible
donc voilà j'ai défendu cet amendement
et je souhaite vraiment parce que là cet
objet de consensus et sur sa
signification et sur le fait qu'ils
rapportent de l'argent à l'état dans
cette situation que bien entendu il n'y
a pas de clivage superflu pour le vote
de cet amendement
si monsieur assouline sur le rapporteur
général
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement qui a été brillamment
présenté par david assouline comme
d'habitude propose de créer une taxe sur
les cessions petit un éditeur de
services de communication de visuels et
je voulais lui dire d'ores et déjà que
je suis favorable à cet amendement
puisque il s'agit de réguler la revente
spéculative de sociétés détentrices de
fréquences c'est qui a été rectifiée de
façon à supprimer son caractère
rétroactif c'est ce que nous avions un
moment retenu comme une objection en
commission des finances et le fait de
l'avoir rectifier dans ce sens je crois
lui redonne toutes les vertus que nous
souhaitions voir établi cet amendement a
été déposé et adopté par le sénat dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finances
pour 2012
deuxième argument pour y être attentif
et il vise précisément à décourager ce
type d'opération spéculative il avait
été inspiré rappelez-vous par
l'opération réalisée par canal+ en
septembre dernier la chaîne avait en
effet effectué une prise de
participation de 60% dans direct 8 et
direct star au profit du groupe bolloré
cet événement avait ému le monde de
l'audiovisuel et avait inspiré l'action
législative
l'amendement que nous avions fait voter
avait été supprimée par l'assemblée
l'assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture et le gouvernement avait ensuite
déposé un dispositif d'inspiration
similaire en loi de finances
rectificative mais de rédaction plus
complexe à tel point
ce dernier comme l'a dit david assouline
avait été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel du fait que l'assiette
de la taxe proposée par le gouvernement
n'était pas suffisant précise alors ce
n'est pas le cas de la taxe qui est
proposé ici qui est beaucoup plus
clairement précisé à cet égard il ya
plusieurs améliorations il prévoit ce
texte ces nouvelles formulations prévoit
un abattement suffisamment important
pour ne pas pénaliser les pme éditrices
de radio indépendantes qui n'ont aucune
part dans le développement de la tnt
nationale et les entreprises éditrices
de services de télévision locale qui on
le sait peinent à trouver leur équilibre
économique
d'autre part le dispositif repose sur
une rédaction qui re sans re centre
pardon le champ de la taxe sur son
véritable objet à savoir la taxation des
seuls transfert de propriété et enfin
contrairement au dispositif adopté en
décembre le présent amendement
après rectification par son auteur n'a
plus de caractère rétroactif puisque les
dispositions s'appliqueraient seulement
à compter du 26 juillet 2012
pour toutes ces raisons il nous semble
souhaitable que cet amendement soit
adopté la commission a donné un avis
favorable bien merci monsieur
l'important général monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président gouvernement
comprend très bien les intentions de
l'auteur de l'amendement adhère dans
l'esprit aux raisons qui ont poussé le
rapporteur général a donné un avis
favorable
j'aurais simplement précisé au nom du
gouvernement qui ne s'agit évidemment
pas de taxer telle société ou de
pénaliser tel acteur du monde industriel
c'est-à-dire une taxe de portée générale
je crois qu'il faut insister sur ce
point
pour autant il paraît difficile
favorable ou défavorable et il s'en
remet donc à la sagesse de l'assemblée
merci monsieur le ministre pour
explication de vote monsieur bah je vous
remercie monsieur le président il me
serait agréable de pouvoir dire au
président assouline que le groupe ump
pourrait soutenir cet amendement
malheureusement je vois un certain
nombre d'inconvénients à son adoption
je vois bien que on a fait un sort
particulier aux petites entreprises
audiovisuelles
mais il n'ya pas que des petites
entreprises audiovisuelles qu'ils
peuvent rencontrer des difficultés et
incriminer toute vente pour lui imposer
cette taxation punitive présente
l'inconvénient de d'empêcher le bon
fonctionnement d'un marché qui n'est pas
forcément spéculatifs une partie des
ventes peuvent fort bien être inspiré
par la nécessité d'apporter des capitaux
nouveaux à une entreprise qui seraient
en difficulté quelle qu'en soit la
taille et par conséquent je crois que la
disposition qui a été prise pour
atténuer les effets de cette taxe ne
répond pas complètement à l'inquiétude
qu'on peut avoir par rapport à la
création de ce nouveau prélèvement d'une
manière plus générale je voudrais dire
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya un problème
dans ce pays
la première réaction de la majorité
actuelle est de créer un impôt nouveau
pour le régler mais je ne partage pas en
ce qui me concerne cette idée que la
taxation
systématiquement la bonne solution on
l'a vu encore ce matin avec la taxe sur
les logements vacants créé en 1999 sans
qu'elle ait eu d'effet efficace sur la
mise sur le marché des logements vacants
et dont on augmente le taux on le voit
de nouveau cet après midi avec ce nouvel
impôt qui ne me paraît pas être le bon
instrument pour régler un problème qui
est un véritable problème et je
comprends moi aussi les bonnes
intentions qui ont présidé à la
rédaction de cet amendement il me semble
que on devrait régler ce problème d'une
manière tout à fait efficace en faisant
confiance au conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
l'agrément qui doit être donnée suffit
largement pour empêcher des opérations
spéculatives qui ne seraient pas
justifiées par des motifs d'intérêt
général tenant à la pérennité des
entreprises audiovisuelles voilà la
raison pour laquelle en ce qui me
concerne je voterai contre cet
amendement
merci cher collègue madame blandin je
pense que c'était lendemain est au
contraire très pertinent si les pouvoirs
publics se sont dotés d'une autorité
indépendante le csa pour l'attribution
des fréquences c'est qu'ils savent
combien sont forts les enjeux
d'utilisation public ou marchande de
l'espace public qui permet de faire
circuler les zones
les exigences sont fortes les auditions
rigoureuse et les propositions des
candidats enregistrés et suivi dans la
durée dans la durée jusqu'à ce qu'un
détenteur d'un espace démission qui sans
considère propriétaire bouscule
l'équilibré revendre sa chaîne
confondante dans la même transaction un
bien marchand ce qu'il a construit et un
morceau de bien commun l'espace public
des fréquences l'objet de l'amendement
de notre collègue est donc pour le moins
ce que l'on doit faire taxer cette
transaction
cet amendement fut d'ailleurs je le dis
en tant que présidente de la commission
culture
voter dans le dernier budget dans notre
assemblée par une majorité qui allait du
groupe crc au groupe ump
et je m'étonne qu'il est partiellement
changé d'avis je ne sais pas ce que
feront nos collègues etc son altération
à l'assemblée par une rédaction
maladroite qui l'a fait tomber
nous soutenons donc résolument cette
taxe en estimant chers collègues vous
avez raison que des régulations plus
vertueuse encore devront voir le jour
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
collectif budgétaire
et nous parlons de taxes merci même lent
d'un monsieur frécon monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues je vous récemment attiré
l'attention sur une question de date il
ne faudrait pas que le conseil
constitutionnel puisse nous censurer une
fois de plus là dessus
le texte qui nous est proposé dit que ce
sera applicable à pas compter du 26
juillet c'est à dire aujourd'hui
or le texte ne sera pas votre fini de
voter aujourd'hui
il sera fini de voter probablement le 30
ou le 31 après la sienne après la cmp
il ne faudrait pas que cette différence
de quelques jours puisse être comptés à
notre débit merci monsieur frécon mam
goulet oui c'est le président subissent
les chers collègues et moi je vais
soutenir cet amendement qui est plein de
bon sens d'autant que l'appel au csa me
semble pas tout à fait pertinent nous
avons dans nos régions pas mal de
difficultés pour obtenir aussi du
pluralisme
en ce qui concerne la répartition et
l'acquisition du réseau hertzien et en
normandie notamment on commence à
constater beaucoup de concentration
donc moi je pense que cet argent sera
bien placé et que monsieur assouline a
parfaitement raison même si bavarde
pendant que je défends son amendement de
déposer cet amendement que je soutiens
comme boulet monsieur assouline
monsieur assouline vous avez demandé
pour explication de vote
bien j'ai j'ai écouté je ne considère
pas pour l'instant que la terre de votre
intervention représenter le groupe pop
et parce que je sais très bien pour en
avoir discuté et dans ma commission avec
avec eux ce qui représente l'ump et plus
largement je regarde le vote de l'année
dernière et ce type d'argument n'a
jamais été employée je vais même vous
dire on m'a reproché linverse notamment
au csa leur réflexion
ils sentent tellement que l'esprit de la
tnt et deux de leurs délibérations pour
attribuer des fréquences est en danger
avec le fait qu'on puisse spéculer sur
ce qu'ils ont donnés gratuitement
que cherchait des dispositifs
d'interdiction et moi qui suis disons
plus modérée je pense qu'il faut des
dispositifs qui qui dissuade qui
dissuade et qui en tous les cas quand
ils n'ont pas réussi à dissuader ont la
vertu de faire que l'état s'y retrouve
un peu et c'est pas grand-chose 5 %
puisque certains disaient mais c'est
rien etc
je disais bon commençons par là donc
franchement il ya quelque chose de très
important
nous avons à faire et c'est vrai dans un
paysage audiovisuel qui pour résister
dans une concurrence internationale dit
il faut qu'on se concentre conçoit des
gros groupes de plus en plus et donc
souvent des antennes qui se ressemblent
mais qui offrent 10 titres pour dire la
même chose ou pour projeter la même
chose
la tnt c'est l inverse c'était dire il
ya des nouveaux ils peuvent être petit
mais il ya plus si gros il y en a 20 ans
plus aujourd'hui on vient d'attribuer
encore six chaînes et on voit que c'est
des gros derrière je comprends cette
nécessité d'avoir des groupes fort est
en même temps on doit tenir au maximum
et jamais incité à cela plus tôt tiré
dans le sens initial voulue par le
législateur et pas ceux qui ont fait la
tnt
voilà ça nous est demandée par tous les
professionnels
et c'est pas une affaire de droite ou de
gauche alors cette taxe et elle va
rapporter de l'argent tout de suite à
l'état et c'est bien pour nous tous et
c'est bien pour la nation et elle va
donner un signe pour des pratiques plus
vertueuse dans ces milieux et moi aussi
je ne désigne personne à la vindicte à
travers cet amendement c'est un
amendement de portée générale et
j'espère qu'il sera voté dans le plus
gros consensus de notre assemblée
merci monsieur assouline monsieur
delattre ce président est monsieur je
voterai cet amendement de monsieur
assouline et très volontiers parce que
non seulement je pense que c'est plus
values ont trois quatre ans absolument
anormal a pâti d'une autorisation
administrative mais qui plus est je
pense monsieur rapporteur général qui a
sûrement un peu d'évasion fiscale
puisque le plus values s'est transformée
reste à voir ce droit des affaires
certes mais s'est transformé en le fait
que monsieur bolloré devenu actionnaire
de référence de vie lundi à rien vrai
problème de pluralisme et nous est cher
collègue de l'ump qui ont vécu ce manque
de pluralisme dans toutes les campagnes
électorales dernière
toute mesure et tout amendement qui
ferait que nous puissions à fléchir le
sens des choses seraient les bienvenus
et c'est vrai ce qu'a rappelé notre ami
à d'autres collègues excusez-moi
insuline de dire que la tnt devait tête
à un instrument de pluralisme et site
complètement anormal aujourd'hui que non
seulement le cssa le sait ça dit je ne
suis pas d'accord avec cette acrobatie
financière et que j'ai pas les moyens
mais là ça sera aux législateurs du
dernier mois hier monsieur assouline
j'ai vu vous avez fait des propositions
de loi d'ailleurs il ya deux ans je me
suis même inspiré d'une pour faisant
proposés dans cette forme prochain avec
le groupe ump pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse se faire avoir à la fois des
groupes mais aussi du pluralisme parce
que nous a quand même pas échappé que
derrière les journalistes qu on accusa
s'est volontairement de peut prendre
parti souvent contre nous il y a quand
même les groupes industriels
il ya quand même des groupes économiques
qui sont derrière et que cette
concentration
arrivé à la veille d'échéances aussi
importante où on a vu et ça profiter à
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 faut être
objectif
ça vous a profité c'est le syndrome du
favori dès lors que les sondages ont
annoncé six sept mois avant qu'il y
avait un favori tous les grands médias
qui ont besoin de la commande publique
on les connaît tous d'un seul coup ils
sont dix n'assume ton pas l'avenir et on
a eu des choses aussi et ça ordinaire
que monsieur pinault magnifique le seul
le solde de madère qui semblait du
centre-droit devenir complètement plus
que centre-gauche et nous avons connu un
vrai problème le pluralisme et je vais
vous choqué notamment en me disant que
si nous avions une campagne les sept
huit derniers mois plus équilibré je ne
suis pas sûr que le résultat a été le
même
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à monsieur a tué
merci monsieur le président moi je
voterai cet amendement plus précisément
je revoterai ce dispositif
je pense qu'il est fondé qu'il est juste
et du gouvernement à doit être attentif
aux conditions dans lesquelles sont
délivrer ces autorisations de licence
lorsqu'elles sont payantes je pense aux
fréquences de téléphones mobiles c'est
formidable de concéder une quatrième
licence mais quand on voit l'impact sur
les sociétés et les opérateurs
et lorsque l'état ou la caisse des
dépôts et consignations sont
actionnaires de ces opérateurs
on peut dire que les moins values
constatées vont bien au-delà de ce que
l'état a pu percevoir donc qu'il y soit
mis bon ordre et que on régule un peu
ces transactions me paraît relever d'une
bonne l'administration publique c'est la
raison pour laquelle je voterai cet
amendement merci président a tué la
parole est à monsieur kétou merci
monsieur le président en complément des
différentes interventions qui ont
précédé je voudrais donner la position
de notre groupe qui est très clair sur
ce sujet dans la mesure où il s'agit
d'une disposition qui a déjà été voté et
nous l'avons voté et je voudrais qu'ici
chacun soient convaincus de la nécessité
de légiférer en la matière nous devons
éviter deux choses premièrement la
spéculation dans ce domaine comme dans
d'autres tout ce qui peut éviter
l'incitation à la spéculation doit être
encouragé et il ya nécessité
malheureusement de taxer ici pour éviter
la spéculation et la deuxième chose
c'est que nous devons éviter aussi la
concentration
s'il est fréquent se trouve reprise par
des groupes qui ont les moyens de
racheter et bien nous obtiendrons un
résultat absolument inverse de celui qui
est poursuivie en attribuant ces
fréquences je voudrais quand même posé
quelques questions à l'auteur de
l'amendement
houas rapporteur au revoir ministre
concernant la la coexistence d'une
éventuelle imposition servait plus value
avec cette taxe cet axe portera bien sûr
là sur la valeur de revente ou d'apport
des titres
dois je comprendre que cette valeur le
plus souvent sera égal au montant de la
plus value réalisée dans la mesure où
les fréquences sont attribuées
gratuitement si oui je trouve que le
taux de 5% pratiqué est plutôt faible
puisqu'il est nettement plus bas que le
taux d'imposition des plus values
la deuxième chose c'est que la bande
mans l'abattement de 1 million d'euros
paraît taux favorable à ceux qui opèrent
ce type de revente
je me demande si on devrait pas le
l'abaisser enfin quant au délai qui est
prévu pour payer le pour payer la taxe
on prévoit de reporter au 1er mai de
l'année suivant l'opération
je me demande s'il est judicieux
d'attendre un tel délai alors que
l'imposition de la plus-value sur titres
sont les règles générales du code
général des impôts se fera dans un
délais plus rapprochés
bien sûr le groupe votera c'est cet
amendement c'est mon cher collègue je
n'ai plus demandes d'intervention donc
je vous rappelle l'avis favorable de la
commission et sagesse pour le
gouvernement alors sur cet amendement
207 rectifié quater qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté mes chers collègues
j'informe le sénat que la commission
mixte paritaire chargée de proposer un
texte sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi relatifs au
harcèlement sexuel est parvenu à
l'adoption d'un texte commun
après l'article 8 nous sommes saisis
d'un amendement 122 qui est présentée
par monsieur dantec où monsieur l'abbé
122 monsieur dantec
oui donc l'amendement 122 consiste à
remettre en cause l' avantage qui est
donné aux véhicules diesel dans les
flottes des parcs d'entreprises du fait
de la de la tva je crois que cet
amendement s'inscrit totalement dans les
déclarations d'arnaud montebourg autour
du développement de la voiture propre
le plan qu'il a présenté hier et je
crois que là on a eu une aberration
puisque finalement nous avons un
avantage fiscal vis-à-vis de la voiture
diesel par rapport aux autres véhicules
et aux véhicules propres
donc je crois qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
de remettre en cause cet avantage un peu
un est cohérent avec la stratégie
industrielle que nous cherchons
aujourd'hui à mettre en place
cela représenterait pour l'état une
économie de 350 millions d'euros
ça n'est pas rien je crois qu'il faut
surtout insister sur le fait que les les
flottes de véhicules d'entreprises se
renouvelle plus tôt plus rapidement que
les flottes de particulier que donc là
nous aurions une incitation au fait de
passer là aussi à la voiture propre plus
rapidement pour ses flottes
d'entreprises et donc ça viendrait
évidemment en soutien des autres
décisions prises par le gouvernement en
incitations notamment dans le cas du
bonus malus crois que c'est l'occasion
aussi de redire ici à quel point il faut
pour l'avenir de l'industrie automobile
française sortir le plus rapidement
possible des filières diesel ce sont des
filières dangereuses pour la santé
humaine nous avons aujourd'hui l' oms et
de nombreux rapports qui le disent nous
avons là une impasse industriels il faut
en sortir je crois que c'était le sens
des déclarations d'arnaud montebourg
donc je vous propose cet amendement pour
qu'on soit en cohérence avec la
stratégie industrielle du gouvernement
en s'appuyant sur le renouvellement des
flottes d'entreprises merci monsieur
dantec pour la commission la gym sur la
porte en général oui monsieur le
président cet amendement il est simple
dans son principe il propose de
supprimer l'avantagé fiscal qui est
accordé aux véhicules diesel et bien sûr
la commission des finances n'est pas
insensible à la philosophie qui guide
de cette démarche et
c'est qui est un sujet aussi récurrent
dans nos débats fiscaux de pub dior z
est alors d'autant plus que plusieurs
rapports récents notamment celui piloté
par guillaume sainteny du conseil
d'analysé stratégique ont fait état de
la nocivité de certaines aides publiques
pour l'environnement et la santé donc il
ya lieu de réfléchir à l'ensemble de ses
incidences et de cette nocivité et je
crois que le gouvernement est bien
conscient de cette préoccupation
sociétale qui lie à aujourd'hui et c'est
la raison pour laquelle une conférence
environnementale a été envisagée pour le
mois de septembre monsieur le ministre
vous et nous le confirmer et il nous
semble donc que pour que cette mesure
puisse assister dans un plan global qui
prenne en compte toutes considérations
liées au carburant aux énergies et aux
transports on puisse avoir peut-être
cette mesure intégrée dans cette
problématique d'ensemble
à la lumière de cette conférence
environnementale du mois de septembre
donc notre souhait c'est de vous
proposer le retrait pour l'instant dans
la tente donc de l'automne où cette
démarche globale va pouvoir être engagée
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président cette
question sera comme viennent d'indiquer
votre rapporteur général évidemment
traiter lors de la conférence
environnementale laquelle aura à se
pencher sur un problème de droit qui ne
me paraît pas simple à traiter est en
tout cas certainement pas à régler dans
le cadre de la séance qui nous rassemble
cet après-midi en effet vous n'ignorez
pas l'existence d'une directive
communautaire prise en 2006 et qui rend
juridiquement impossible la non
déductibilité de biens intermédiaires en
l'espèce le gazole que vous proposez
pourtant de ne pas rendre déductibles
comme il est aujourd'hui en effet si les
sens elle ne l'est pas c'est parce que
au moment où la directive a été prise
cette situation prévalait déjà et qu'il
est constant lorsqu une directive
est prise en tout cas proposé puis
adopté qu'il est constant que le droit
préalable demeure si le droit à venir
est conditionnée précisément par cette
directive
j'ajoute que si le parlement a adopté
cet amendement
cela non seulement ne serait pas endroit
très pérenne car naturellement nous
serions condamnés mais de surcroît cela
fragiliserait la situation de la france
aujourd'hui qui contrairement à d'autres
pays n'autorise pas la non déductibilité
de l'essence
puisque je voulais indiqué c'était la
situation qui prévalait avant l'adoption
de la directive et donc je crois qu'il
serait prudent comme les députés du
groupe écologiste l'ont fait à
l'assemblée nationale que vous retiriez
cet amendement sous le bénéfice des
explications que je me suis permis de
vous donner renvoyant à la confiance
environnementale le soin de définir les
voies et moyens qui permettraient
d'aboutir à une situation dont je ne
doute pas qu'elle serait certainement
préférable à celle qui existe
aujourd'hui situation que par voie
d'amendement je ne crois pas pour des
raisons juridiques européennes possible
de corriger
donc si vous ne retirez pas cet
amendement je serai obligé de donner un
avis défavorable à son adoption
monsieur dantec oui j'ai bien entendu
l'ouverture du rapporteur
je crois que y compris dans la position
du ministre on voit bien l'incohérence
aujourd'hui du système puisque
finalement sûr sûr sûr les sens nous
n'avons pas le même système au niveau de
la tva
donc je le retire au vu de la difficulté
technique mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
du coup c'est une question qui est sur
la table sur lesquels ils n'en ont
pourra pas garder cette incohérence de
traitement entre le diesel d'un côté les
sens de l'autre
sur le président de la commission
finances gouvernement ce ministre du
budget portant sur un sujet connexe
chacun a pu prendre connaissance du plan
de soutien à l'automobile et des moyens
supplémentaires et qu'il fait figurer en
faveur du système bonus malus
j'ai cru comprendre que dans ce plan de
soutien
il y avait des financements d'ordre très
divers si j'ai bien compris et pardonnez
moi je parle de mémoire des sommes issus
du grand emprunt
des sommes susceptibles d'être allouées
par oseo et donc qui qui qui doivent
être affectés mais dont le financement
existent déjà et enfin et c'est là ma
question monsieur le ministre
des éléments d'ordre budgétaire sans
doute nouveau que de mémoire je situe à
quelque chose compris entre 150 et 200
millions d'euros
peut-être nous direz vous quel est le
bon ordre de grandeur et plus exactement
plus précisément puisque nous débattons
d'un projet de loi de finances
rectificative
ces financements que l'on présente comme
étant une décision est ce que pour leur
partie budgétaire est ce que ces
financements ont déjà une existence dans
les lois de finances déjà voté ou dans
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
ou en d'autres termes n'annonceront pas
des sommes qui n'existe pas encore ou
qui ne pourrait être financée que par de
nouvelles augmentations de prélèvements
ou par des réductions d'autres dépenses
publiques donc monsieur le ministre
puisque l'amendement du groupe
écologiste que j'ai repris quelques
instants de raison
parler des aspects environnementaux liés
à la consommation de carburant pardonnez
moi d'y avoir lié les aspects
environnementaux liés aux différentes
formes de motorisation d'où ma question
sur le plan de soutien du secteur
automobile merci monsieur marini y at il
des explications de vote
voulant tirer donc le 122 et retiré
après l'article 8 je suis saisi une
seule fois monsieur le président at hui
je suis saisi après l'article 8 d'un
amendement numéro 123 qu'est présentée
par monsieur l'abbé monsieur l'abbé oui
merci monsieur le président de celle
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
cet amendement que j'ai déposée vis à
supprimer l'avantagé fiscal accordé aux
agrocarburants elle représente sur
l'année 2012
une perte de 196 millions d'euros pour
le budget de l'état selon le rapport de
la cour des comptes publié en janvier
2012 sur la période allant de 2005 à
2010 la filière agricole productrice
d'agrocarburants a profité de deux
milliards 6,2 dépenses fiscales cumulées
pour 1,5 milliard d'euros
d'investissements du point de vue
strictement économique le maintien de
cette niche fiscale n'est pas justifiée
puisque les investissements ont été
faits et sont déjà largement rentabilisé
il s'agit là tout d'abord d'une question
de justice fiscale
d'autant plus que pour nous écologistes
les efforts au regard de la dette
n'auront de sens que s'ils s'inscrivent
dans une stratégie générale de
transition écologique énergétique
transition visant à effacer l'autre
dette immense que vous ne nous avons à
l'égard des générations futures la dette
environnementale
les mesures de l'état devront maintenant
intégré la notion de sobriété
au lieu de poursuivre la fuite en avant
dans le domaine des transports et
déplacements comme dans les autres
dans ce même rapport on apprend la vie
de la direction générale du trésor et je
cite les producteurs d'oeufs
carburant compte tenu de l'importance de
la pénalité représenté par la tgap et de
la possibilité de la récupérer de la
répercuter sur le consommateur
ce qu'il ne manque pas de faire
bénéficie d'une rente assimilable à une
subvention
par ailleurs je cite toujours le rapport
faire du soutien aux biocarburants
paraître peu approprié dans la mesure où
les exploitations concernées sont déjà
les plus riches est bénéficiaire d'un
soutien public plus important que la
moyenne dans le cadre de la pac justice
l'état subventionne une industrie
bénéficiaires mais en plus de cela le
développement des arguments se fait au
détriment du pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs
en effet ceux ci paient les
agrocarburants intégré à l'essence ou au
gazole mais les performances
énergétiques sont moindres
depuis tout point de vue écologique rien
ne justifie cette niche fiscale parle
pas que le centre d'un oeil stratégique
juge dommageables à la biodiversité
ce qui est également confortée par
l'ademe et je parle là des biocarburants
évidemment de première génération ceux
qui sont des agrocarburants parce que ce
sont des agrocarburants soutenir des
agrocarburants c'est aussi comme l'a
rappelé la fao soutenir une politique
qui a pour un effet indéniable la hausse
des prix des denrées alimentaires au
niveau mondial au risque de nouvelles
émeutes de la faim
et puis dans les pays du sud les
cultures d'agrocarburants participent à
cette scandaleuse pratique de
l'accaparement des terres 128 millions
d'hectares ces dix dernières années et
la part des agro carburants représentent
à elles seules deux fois la surface
agricole de la france a donc autant de
points qui font que cette exonération
maintenant n'a plus lieu d'être
et donc je demande avec force de voter
cette suppression qui représente je le
rappelle une perte de 196 millions
d'euros pour l'état merci monsieur
l'abbé monsieur le rapporteur général
prévu de la commission
merci monsieur le président on va
écouter le point de vue sera exactement
le même que précédemment puisque là
aussi ont fait diligence pour valider
une option qui évidemment tout à fait
intéressante et utile
mais comme là aussi la conférence
environnementale a vocation à se saisir
de ce dossier et ceci c'est pas dans six
mois ou dans un an c'est dans quelques
semaines le temps que la chaleur du mois
d'août laissent la place à la capacité
de réflexion du mois de septembre et et
et le dossier sera dès lors certainement
débattue à cette conférence donc je
suggère dans cette attente et dans
l'espoir d'un aboutissement fructueux je
suggère le retrait merci monsieur
important général est aussi ministre je
vous ai indiqué monsieur le sénateur
l'abbé les raisons pour lesquelles tout
à l'heure je souhaitais amendement
pardon soit retiré ses raisons me
semble-t-il s'impose à nouveau cet
amendement est peut-être prématuré
d'abord dans l'action du gouvernement
je vous indiquais ce qu'était ce
programme il me semble que agir de
manière concertée avec un plan
d'ensemble serait préférable même si je
comprends très bien la liberté qui est
la vôtre en amendant un projet de loi
mais reprenant à mon compte
pendant de me répéter les explications
du rapporteur général je jugerai
préférable que vous leur terrier
d'autant que des agréments sont en cours
et qu adopter cet amendement ici puis le
cas échéant commission mixte paritaire
et à l'assemblée reviendrait à créer un
régime d'instabilité juridique dont les
actuels bénéficiaires risquerait de
demander dans une forme ou sous une
autre à l'état de lui rendre compte de
leur rendre compte donc je préférais que
vous retiriez cet amendement je ne vous
le cache pas il ne s'agit pas d'une des
fausses ou l'allemand s'est clairement
engagé dans le cadre d'une conférence
qui se tiendra comme l'a indiqué le
reporter général une fois que la pluie
sera revu
j'ai cru comprendre que c'était le
souhait du ps de la commission des
finances bref au coeur de cet été la
chose paraît prématuré à défaut de
rencontrer un désaccord de principe
entre vous et le gouvernement monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances et avec l'autorisation du
sénateur l'abbé je me permets de
répondre à la question vous avez posé en
reprenant opportunément l'amendement qui
fut retiré je remercie d'ailleurs de
l'occasion que vous avez su saisir pour
assurer un certain écho aux propositions
du gouvernement dont j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il ne caché chez vous aucune ironie
vous sembliez adhérer à cela alors il
est vrai qu'une partie de ce financement
se fait avec un jeu à somme nulle
puisque il y aura une incitation sous la
forme d'un bonus vous connaissez le
principe laquelle incitations sera
financé par un malus
le bonus malus ressortait déjà du
grenelle de l'environnement le bonus
malus avait déjà été mis en oeuvre
d'ailleurs par le gouvernement précédent
nous allons essayer d'en cerner
peut-être davantage l'objet afin que son
efficacité soit plus avérée et son coût
mieux maîtriser quant à son coût et
comme vous le savez dès lors qu'une
disposition est adopté et même si la
chose peut être délicate par voie de
rescrit est toujours envisageable
d'anticiper sur ces dispositions
favorables étant entendu que les gens de
bonne compagnie
proteste rarement contre un avantage qui
bénéficie à la collectivité fut-il un
avantage dont bénéficierait celles et
ceux qui auraient souhaité en bénéficier
avant même que la loi dessus voter
j'espère que ces explications là nous
aurons satisfaite et merci encore
d'avoir assuré la publicité requise à ce
plan dont je devine qui vous a
probablement satisfaits
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
l'abbé
dionne monsieur le ministre le débat à
voix va avoir lieu dans le cadre de la
conférence environnementale
effectivement mais king qui en a qui
n'aura pas pour objectif de décider
évidemment si ce n'est de débattre
maintenant cet amendement nord pour le
moment parce qu'on attend le débat ne
remet pas en cause les agrocarburants tu
parce qu'ils peuvent continuer de
fonctionner parce qu'ils bénéficient
aussi d'autres avantages de tgap je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure
et puis cet engagement 10% de l'europe
où l'état français a anticipé pour aller
plus vite encore et puis chez nous il
s'agit du bio diesel donc mon collègue
grenon dantec a parlé tout à l'heure de
la problématique du diesel ce qui est
une véritable problématique de santé
publique
il faut dire aussi les choses telles
qu'elles sont il y à milly a une
structure qui s'appelle sophie
sofiprotéol très lié à la fnsea
tout le monde le sait je crois qu'il
faut dire les choses et qui celle-là une
forme de monopole et qui bénéficie je
crois que c'est de l'ordre de 80% de ces
de cette aide à elle toute seule je
crois que là on parle parce que le
priant de la république avait avait
annoncé toutes les mesures que nous
prenons pour pour économiser tout le
monde les comprendra il y à des
françaises et des français qui souffrent
énormément
il ya ceux qui ne souffrent pas et qui
peuvent être à même de faire des efforts
et des efforts à ces contrôles entendu
ce matin qu'ils peuvent le comprendre
dans la mesure où il ya une notion
supérieure de justice
et cet amendement va dans le sens de la
justice et un sud pour moi pour nous
c'est un acte posé que l'on attend c'est
la raison pour laquelle et je le dis
monsieur le ministre sans aucune
animosité
parce que nous nous nous sommes et d'une
façon très loyal dans la majorité
par contre avec des exigences et celle
là en est une je prendre je pourrais
comprendre les positionnements au niveau
des votes d'autant plus qu'il y aura le
débat ce que l'on attend ce sont des
engagements pour le projet de loi de
finances 2013
je maintiens l'amendement je vous le
voulez dit voilà que j'ai que j'ai
plaidé sur un fond de justice merci
merci monsieur l'abbé monsieur savary
oui merci merci une supposition monsieur
le ministre je crois que on ne peut pas
rester sans voix par rapport à ce qui a
été dit quand on connaît un peu les
filières de l'agro-industrie et
notamment le thème de la bioraffinerie
végétales dont les agrocarburants ne
sont que la partie visible de l iceberg
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit par des
voies propres les voies fermentaires de
transformer la plante en entier donc on
maintient avec du blé ont fait du blé
bien qu'on puisse faire d'autres
débouchés mais ce qui permet avec la
paille de fer des transformations aux
différents tels que de la pâte à papier
des pâtes aux délits nine qui sont des
produits à valeur ajoutée et donc on
transforme la plante en entier non pas
avec des sous produits
mais avec un ensemble de co produit et
cela nécessite des recherches
indispensable les agrocarburants ne sont
que la première phase dans ce domaine de
la biographie shihri bio raffinerie
végétale c'est à dire les
biotechnologies blanches de
transformation d'un ensemble de process
industriels qui vont créer les emplois
de demain par rapport aux emplois
d'aujourd'hui donc véritablement
s'attaquer à cette filière si une fois
de plus s'attaquer à l'emploi et à
l'ensemble des entreprises qui tourne
autour de cela c'est donner un mauvais
signe à la filière agricole ce qui s'est
particulièrement investi dans le domaine
de la recherche et de l'innovation
c'est la raison pour laquelle je serais
personnellement et probablement nous
serons nombreux
je l'espère en tout cas à être opposés à
cet amendement qui mettrait en péril dès
à présent car de quoi s'agit-il quand on
parle de recherche autour des
agrocarburants c'est de la recherche sur
la transformation en entier de la plante
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y à un
certain nombre de crédits qui ont été
investis qui ne sont pas contrairement à
ce qui est dit rentabiliser pour
l'instant et ils permettent de nouveaux
débouchés
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
continuer si on veut demain faire entre
autres également des carburants à base
de biomasse à base de fétuque ou havas
d'autres plantes
c'est comme ça que
on pourra y arriver et trouver une
certaine dépendance énergétique merci
merci monsieur savary monsieur des
trains oui merci le seul président de me
donner la parole notre collègue savary a
bien expliqué l'un des aspects
prometteur des travaux qui sont menés
sur la plante entière et je sais que nos
collègues qui souhaite que l'on mette un
terme au développement des biocarburants
de première génération sont favorable à
ce qu'on poursuive les recherches sur
les biocarburants de deuxième génération
c'est-à-dire la plante entière et pas
seulement le produit qui peut être
utilisée effectivement pour la
nourriture sauf que si on veut arriver à
la deuxième génération
il faut déjà aller au bout de la
première génération on ne passe pas à la
deuxième génération sans avoir travaillé
à fond la première génération c'est le
premier point que je voulais mettre en
avant le deuxième point c'est que si on
n'aide pas la filière française qui
contrairement à ce qui est dit n'a pas
encore amorti
loin de là ces investissements dans
l'est dans les biocarburants de première
génération et bien on ne réduira pas la
vente de bio carburants en france sauf
que ce seront des bio carburants venus
d'asie du brésil où des d'amérique du
nord qui envahiront la france
biocarburants qui eux sont très aidés
sont très aidé beaucoup plus que le sont
les biocarburants de première génération
produits en france alors ça c'est un
véritable enjeu c'est un véritable enjeu
en termes également de balance
commerciale je rappelle parce que je
sais qu'il ya un péché originel pour
certains de nos concitoyens sur ces
biocarburants qui est que effectivement
c'est bio carburants sont produits dans
des régions où l'agriculture est
productive oui l'agriculture et
productive et elle rapporte un excédent
à la balance commerciale de notre pays
de 10 milliards d'euros par an
l'équivalent de 32 airbus dès qu'on vend
dix airbus on en parle on en parle on
parle pas une seule fois dans l'année
des excédents qu apporte l
balance commerciale de notre pays cette
agriculture productive et cette
agriculture productive c'est celle qui
permet aussi à notre pays d'être
exportateurs dans ce domaine alors
évidemment moi j'ai rien contre la
l'agriculture biologique je crois qu'il
ya de la place pour les deux mais si
l'agriculture biologique aujourd'hui
disons le clairement la production de
l'agriculture biologique c'est 40% de la
production en termes de rendement à
l'hectare de la production de
l'agriculture conventionnelle que nous
connaissons et grands grâce à laquelle
grâce à laquelle l'europe et
indépendante dans un domaine et grâce à
laquelle nous sommes exportateurs de
produits sains de produits alimentaires
et de produits agricoles et de produits
agricoles transformés
donc je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention à ça certes les biocarburants
de première génération ne sont pas une
fin en soi
certes ils ne sont pas parfaits mais ils
sont le point de passage obligé pour
arriver effectivement à ces
biocarburants de deuxième génération qui
eux utilisent rond la plante entière et
transformeront aussi des produits autres
que des produits alimentaires c'est cela
vers lequel nous sommes tous d'accord
pour aller mais ne coupons pas les
jambes aux entreprises qui sont
justement sur le chemin de cette
réussite
merci monsieur détraigne monsieur le
président à tuer merci monsieur le
président je voudrais mettre à profit
cette discussion d'amendements pour
interroger à mon tour le ministre est la
concomitance entre la présentation
l'adoption par le conseil des ministres
d'un plan en faveur de la filière
automobile et notre discussion
budgétaire
n'aurait-elle pas justifié que nous
puissions avoir connaissance de l'impact
budgétaire de ce plan car il n'est pas
douteux que il affectera les finances
publiques au titre de l'année 2012 et de
ce point de vue monsieur le ministre
y at il une affectation du grand emprunt
dans le financement de tout ou partie de
ses opérations
et si tel est le cas il faudra
reconnaître que
c'est le budget 2010 qui finalement aura
financé une partie de votre plan de la
filière automobile
car cette opération de com entend prat
vous en conviendrez était une grande
habileté de présentation budgétaire
puisque les 35 milliards ont été pris en
charge par le budget 2010 alors même que
les dépenses n'interviendront que sur
une période de cinq à dix ans suivant
l'année 2010 de cela vous saurai gré et
sans doute au gouvernement précédent
merci madame beau fils monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues je crois que notre
collègue monsieur l'abbé à poser de
vraies questions par rapport à ce
problème posé par les biocarburants
moi je suis interrogative
quand je vois la façon dont on a
développé cette pratique dans nos
secteurs agricoles sans véritable
réflexion de fond sur ce qu'était la
capacité des terres agricoles qu'on a
utilisées pour ces biocarburants par
rapport aux capacités que ces terres
pouvait nous apporter pour répondre aux
besoins du tri tiff de notre pays et
faire qu'on soit beaucoup plus efficace
quand je dis besoins nutritifs c'est pas
besoins alimentaires immédiats pour les
habitants c'est aussi le besoin en
production nécessaire pour alimenter le
bétail
c'est aussi cette cette partie là donc
je pense qu'on a un vrai problème de
travail de fond sur ces sur ces sujets
et j'ai bien entendu ce que viennent de
dire certains nos collègues ou sur la
recherche de la deuxième génération ou
sur les biocarburants venant de
l'étranger mais c'est pas parce que des
biocarburants viennent chez nous
fabriqué à l'étranger avec des aides
importantes mais qui sont aussi des
aides qui sont apportées sur des
secteurs qui sont destructeurs pour les
pays où ils sont produits que nous nous
devons rentrer dans cette démarche
donc je crois qu'il faut un véritable
problème alors est-ce qu'il faut voter
immédiatement ou est-ce qu'il faut se
donner
et peut-être de moi je ne sais pas si
monsieur le ministre peut nous dire dans
combien de temps se fera la conférence
sur ce sujet mais peut-être faut-il se
donner le petit temps là de travail de
fond qui permettrait à la fois de mettre
au point ces questions sur le domaine
agricole et sur le domaine des
biocarburants pour être le plus efficace
possible sur ce sujet nous nous
abstiendrons mais c'est une abstention
positive
merci madame beau fils monsieur lézard
merci monsieur le président au service
mes chers collègues nous en ce qui nous
concerne nous ne voterons pas cet
amendement car nous considérons qu'il
n'est pas raisonnable systématiquement à
la fois de faire le procès de
l'utilisation du diesel des
agrocarburants du kérosène nous sommes à
une période où notre filière automobile
connaît les difficultés que l'on connaît
où il est nécessaire d'avoir une
approche et c'est le lay qui parle non
pas religieuses de ces problèmes mais à
la fois sociétale économique et qu'on ne
peut pas traiter ces problèmes de fond
qui intègre aussi et notre collègue la b
à raison des questions de santé qu'il ne
faut pas sous-estimer n'est pas de cette
manière là parce que ça c'est vraiment
de l'affichage mais ça ne résout
aucunement les problèmes ça ne peut que
les compliqué aussi nous ne pouvons pas
voter ses abonnements merci monsieur
lézard madame la présidente blandin
rapidement monsieur le président
j'entends bien qu'il y a de raison de ne
pas voter l'amendement d'abord parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur le fond et
qu'on soutient les agrocarburants ce qui
n'est pas notre cas
pour des soucis de stratégie
industrielle concertée alors là je
réponds à l'orateur précédent que dès
que la france se met à arrêter de faire
des hybrides adossé au diesel on aura
peut-être des chances d'en vendre dans
d'autres pays que le nôtre ça sera très
bon pour la balance commerciale est
enfin l'autre raison que nous a suggéré
le ministre
c'est d'attendre la conférence
environnementale nous pourrions
l'entendre sauf que cette conférence
environnemental va durer moins de 48
heures se déroulait à la mi septembre
nous n'en saurons donc pas plus
considéré donc le vote au moins de nos
collègues comme autant de petites fiches
de rappel pour la ministre qui va
organiser cette conférence afin qu'elle
n'oublie pas notre volonté de dialogue
sur ce sujet merci même lendemain du
président guillaume président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je crois
que ce sujet le ministre l'a très bien
dit est un sujet de société fondamental
et pourquoi vous ne pourrez pas ne
pouvons pas être favorable à cet
amendement ici parce que nous sommes en
projet de loi rectificatif budgétaire et
que nous avons besoin que ce débat soit
mené au plus profond de la société avec
les associations évidemment avec les
partis politiques et dans ce cadre-là la
conférence environnementale est bien
celle là
moi je ne crois pas qu'il faille se
diviser s'opposer sur ce genre de sujet
il ya ceux qui défendent plus le bio
ceux qui défendent plus le conventionnel
la france a besoin des deux
si on oppose le bio et le conventionnel
on ne s'en sortira pas
le conventionnel est indispensable pour
la balance votre commerce extérieur et
bravo à toutes ces industries
agroalimentaires bravo aux semenciers
bravo à ceux qui exportent et qui font
rentrer de la richesse de notre pays et
en même temps dans beaucoup de
territoire français l'agriculture
biologique est la seule qui peut
permettre aux agriculteurs de s'en
sortir avec des petits rendements mais
qui leur procure des revenus supérieurs
à 6 fait du conventionnel
ça ce n'est pas de la porte
du positionnement politicien c'est une
réalité donc nous aurons besoin à la
fois d'avoir une vraie discussion
stratégique sur quelle agriculture
voulons-nous de notre pays aux années
qui viennent parce que le débat sur les
biocarburants sur les agrocarburants
dans dix ans si on continue comme ça on
l'aura plus parce qu'il n'y aura plus
d'agriculteurs dans notre pays donc il
faudra sauver cette agriculture la
défendent la promouvoir
et le débat sur la pac sera
indispensable c'est le premier point
stratégique
le deuxième point stratégique la
conférence environnementale nous avons
bien vu que le grenelle de
l'environnement et je dis ça madame la
présidente blandin avaient duré des mois
et des mois avec des copines avec des
associations et on voit comment on est
arrivé au grenelle 2 qui a fait pschitt
et dont aujourd'hui les uns et les
autres s'accordent à dire qu'il n'est
pas les résultats ne sont pas à la
hauteur de nos espérances donc une
conférence environnementale monté par le
gouvernement qu'elle durera peut-être 48
heures mais qui mettra la france en
mouvement qui mettra les associations en
mouvement pour arriver à avoir une vraie
stratégie c'est quelque chose
d'important
ce sera là deux grandes la deuxième
grande loi sur laquelle nous aurons à
travailler
quant à ceux à cette séance
d'aujourd'hui
moi je crois vraiment que voter cet
amendement et certains vous nous
pourrions être en accord avec avec cela
mais oui mais je vous explique pourquoi
voter cet amendement
aujourd'hui c'est voir me semble-t-il un
peu par le petit bout de la lorgnette
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
budgétaire rectificatif donc le ministre
a pris des engagements on pourrait vous
pourriez retirer l'amendement le débat a
eu lieu vous êtes exprimés on sait tous
exprimés et puis attendre l'automne pour
reposer peut-être ensemble d'ailleurs
peut-être ensemble reposer un texte
supplémentaire qui nous permettrait
d'aller de l'avant mais c'est vrai qu'en
l'état d' qu en l'état des choses
notre notre groupe ne pourra pas voter
votre votre amendement d'abord parce que
nous suivons la position du gouvernement
mais parce qu'ensuite nous avons une
grande ambition et la grande ambition
c'est le grand débat et c'est le fait de
voter des lois d'orientation des doigts
cadre qui lui permet d'aller plus loin
et de donner de la visibilité merci bien
merci
non il ya déjà eu l'explication de vote
non si vous permettez monsieur le
président tout simplement donc vous
aurez compris ce matin que je chante
j'apprends encore le métier tout à
l'heure j'ai annoncé à vélo chez votre
inspiration
j'ai annoncé l'amendement maintenant il
y a eu des échanges
j'ai entendu la pole et al la position
du parti socialiste
j'ai entendu la volonté forte de mettre
les choses à plat
j'ai entendu je tiens à dire que pour
moi il s'agissait pas de faire le procès
de l'agriculture le débat bla pour le
nom n'était pas agricole il était
énergie biocarburants maintenant sur le
fond il y aura débat effectivement aussi
on en a discuté avec avec le ministre de
l'agriculture sur le choix agricole pour
les années qui viennent
moi j'ai entendu des réponses de court
terme on continue à être dans le court
terme
évidemment il faut continuer de
travailler sur les sur les agressions
les biocarburants de seconde et de
troisième génération là il y aura des
moyens à mettre parce qu'il y aura
besoin de moyens maintenant sur les
agrocarburants la filière marche et la
niche fiscale
elle est justement sur le sur la vente
donc elle ne tient pas maintenant je
suis à même de retirer la demande
l'amendement si je peux encore le
retirer pour éviter la division dans la
tente et une attente et je voulais dire
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
une attendent extrêmement exigeante
autant sur les sujets d'énergie que sur
les sujets agricoles
je vous le rappelle on se place dans une
logique majoritaire pour avancer
ensemble et je voudrais vous parler d'un
dernier mot on a parlé du d'économie de
sociétal je voudrais vous parler
d'éthique parce qu'on en parle pas des
tic
sans les tic notre mode sans intégrer
les tic notre mode de développement
il continuera d'aller dans le mur voilà
ce que j'avais à vous dire et je vous en
remercie de votre écoute bien merci
oui tout à l'heure c'était le maintien
madame keller avait demandé la parole
avant le retrait donc je laisse la
parole
merci monsieur le monde parle avant
c'était initialement pour une
explication de vote
alors chers collègues avec mais mes
collègues du groupe ump on on allait
presque envie de se retirer parce qu'il
y avait un débat interne à la majorité
sénatoriale et présidentielle
et ce débat sûrement intéressant on a le
sentiment qu'il aurait pu se prolonger
longuement or monsieur le ministre
chers collègues on nous a promis qu en
48 heures chrono
c'est comme un grand distributeur
d'ailleurs la conférence du 14 et 15
septembre prochains à les résoudre
la transition énergétique et plus
sérieusement nous sommes nombreux à y
être très attaché
changez de sources d'énergie être plus
attentifs aux limites des ressources
protéger la biodiversité protéger le
cadre de vie de nos concitoyens essayer
de construire une forme de développement
et d'urbanisme plus respectueux des
ressources
on est tous d'accord la question c'est
le chemin pour y arriver
le grenelle de l'environnement a posé
des jalons très fort je forme le voeu
que le 14 et 15 septembre prochains dans
un large consensus
on piste ensemble tous progresser et
monsieur le ministre il fera chaud mois
d'août mais j'espère que vous
travaillerez beaucoup parce que on a
besoin je crois de beaucoup de
concertation et de travail intra
majorité pour arriver à des propositions
réalistes faisable et qui poursuivent au
fond de manière constructive ce que le
grenelle a bien amorcé je vous remercie
bien merci mesdames clair donc tous les
groupes se sont exprimés monsieur labbé
a retiré l'amendement
je suis saisi après l'article 8 d'un
amendement 121 qui est présentée par
monsieur dantec
oui monsieur le président je voudrais
rappeler que le but des amendements
quand on parle loi de finances est
d'abord d'aider le ministre du budget à
boucler le budget et puis d'essayer de
voir s'il n'y a pas des incohérences
dans le le système général et donc c'est
l'esprit cet amendement je voudrais pas
qu'il soit vu uniquement dans un débat
trop générales mais qu'on reste des fois
un peu sur la lettre des amendements
donc ici il s'agit d'abord d'abonder le
budget de la france d'un 3 milliards de
plus je pense qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
d'amendements à plus d'un milliard donc
je voudrais qu'on le l'analyse dans ce
cadre là il s'agit là aussi d'aller
contre une aberration qui est que le
kérosène utilisé par les avions est
exonéré de la taxe intérieure de
consommation daté icpe
alors que nous savons le transport
aérien est fortement émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre au moins le double des
véhicules individuels
donc c'est à la fois une aberration
écologique mais aussi une distorsion de
concurrence je voudrais insister
là-dessus qui est favorable au secteur à
rien par rapport aux autres possibilités
de transport notamment au détriment du
rail ce qui va à l'encontre des
principes qui avait été vu au moment du
grenelle de l'environnement et de ce qui
a été encore dit par le ministre des
transports en audition cette semaine de
la volonté du gouvernement de renforcer
la part du rail dans les mobilités en
france j'insiste aussi sur le fait que
l'amendement nous vous proposons
s'inscrit dans le respect de la
convention de chicago où il est possible
de supprimer cette exonération pour les
vols domestiques que cette situation est
déjà appliqué aux pays bas et en norvège
je voudrais aussi souligner trois autres
points
tout d'abord parce qu'évidemment ça
pourrait venir dans le débat par rapport
à la fragilité actuelle du transporteur
aérien historique en france d'air france
je crois que les exonérations dont
bénéficient les transports aériens
bénéficient d'abord très fortement aux
low cost puisque évidemment les les
coûts qui s'impose aux uns et aux autres
étant réduit en proportion évidemment le
low cost peut proposer des trains des
tarifs beaucoup plus attractif que les
transporteurs classiques qui eux
respectent un certain nombre de normes
sociales et de qualité de service pour
les clients
ça ne va pas du tout dans le sens de la
fragilisation des transporteurs aériens
historique
ensuite bien sûr et cette question est
venu à l'assemblée nationale nous sommes
en temps groupes écologistes très très
sensible à l'aménagement du territoire
et à l'égalité des territoires et bien
évidemment nous pensons aux territoires
notamment des territoires insulaires qui
ont besoin du transport aérien
mais ça n'est pas en rendant le
transport aérien moins cher partout
qu'on aide ces territoires insulaires il
s'agit de trouver d'autres mécanismes et
le fait d'avoir une nouvelle ressource
pour l'état il peut être d'ailleurs
l'occasion de mécanismes de soutien aux
territoires qui sont les plus excentrés
et qui ont à ce niveau là des
difficultés et enfin je voudrais
insister sur un point tout à fait
essentielle qui est la question de le ts
au niveau européen on ne doit pas
confondre la tei cpe et la question de
le ts au niveau européen ce n'est pas
d'abord les mêmes montants
le ts ne permettra jamais de rattraper
ce cadeau concurrentiel qui est fait aux
transports aériens et c'est l'occasion
pour moi au nom du groupe écologiste
insisté sur l'importance absolue que le
gouvernement français et l'europe
continue de défendre l'inscription du
transport aérien dans le ts au niveau
européen
c'est un élément de la crédibilité de
l'europe aujourd'hui dans les
négociations internationales nous
connaissons les pressions contre le ts
pour le transport aérien en europe mais
lâcher sur ce point ça serait décrit
diviser l'europe dans la négociation
internationale sur le climat qui est un
enjeu central donc nous vous proposons
un amendement qui rapportera 1,3
milliard d'euros au budget de l'état et
qui aidera à lutter efficacement contre
l'effet de serre merci et monsieur
dantec
monsieur le rapporteur général pour
l'avis de la commission
oui monsieur le président la position
est la même pour ce troisième amendement
à savoir toujours ce souhait d'avoir une
problématique globale envisagée
et au delà de la conférence
environnementale et quant aux moyens
quant aux moyens je suis pas sûr que la
retraite de strasbourg proposé par
fabienne keller soit de nature à faire
avancer le sujet mais bon pourquoi pas
s'agissant des démons temps je crois que
l'estimation qui est donnée ne nous
paraît pas des plus fiables puisque le
rapport guillaume par les 315 millions
et non pas de 1 milliard 3 donc il
faudra peut-être aussi qu'on regarde
aussi au niveau études d'impact et qu'on
chiffres qu'on voit et éventuellement
convient que ça représente
c'est beaucoup toute façon c'est
beaucoup mais on voit bien qu'il ya 100
au lieu d' affiner la réflexion et est
sans doute de conclure d'ici la
présentation du projet de loi de
finances pour 2013 je pense qu'on aura
avancé un peu après le mois de septembre
donc je préconise le retrait comme pour
les deux merci monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à cet
amendement d'abord pour des questions
juridiques
on peut certes gloser sur la prévalence
de la convention de chicago qui est un
traité prévalence donc de se traiter sur
notre droit interne certains avis
juridique met en cause cette prévalence
mais les mêmes ne met pas en cause après
valence la directive prise en 2003 qui
compliqueraient singulièrement le la
tâche de notre pays si d'aventuré cette
disposition adoptée était attaqué
ensuite il y a un inconvénient de nature
économique certain pays a déjà fait ça
pays bas ça n'est pas tout à fait la
même superficie ça n'est pas non plus
tout à fait les mêmes niveau
d'infrastructures je pense en partie aux
impostures ferroviaire qui existe aux
pays-bas et puis surtout la difficulté
que rencontrerait un certain nombre de
compagnies opérant sur notre territoire
serait de deux ordres
la première ces compagnies seraient
confrontés aux compagnies low cost vous
les avez vous même cité qui elle
organise la vitime en dehors de nos
frontières et bénéficierez d lors d'un
avantage compétitif supérieure encore à
celui dont elle bénéficie deuxième
inconvénient un certain nombre de vols
commencent à l'intérieur de nos
frontières pour se poursuivre à
l'extérieur de celle-ci
comment faire la part des choses dès
lors qu'un passager aurait pris un
billet pour aller toulouse à paris puis
ensuite de paris à francfort de paris
à londres de paris à new york vous voyez
qu'il y aurait des récolement affaires
et des ajustements source d'une
formidable complexité évidemment de
contentieux certainement pas d'une
satisfaction sur le fond pour ces deux
raisons là monsieur le sénateur je vous
engage donc à retirer votre amendement
tout en sachant ce que peut être votre
agacement il est arrivé comme
parlementaire de l'opposition de déposer
des amendements comparable me faire
opposé ses arguments il m'est arrivé
aussi d'entendre ses arguments comme
désagréable aux visées que je pouvais
poursuivre mais ce n'est pas maintenant
que vous allez voir
à voir ce fameux débat parfaitement
décrit par riber entre l'éthique de
responsabilité et l'éthique de
conviction vous suggère de ne pas
renoncer à la vôtre et souffrez que je
respecte la mienne merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur riquier
monsieur le président à monsieur le
ministre les chats collègues je
comprends très bien la philosophie de
cet amendement déposé par notre collègue
dantec par le groupe écologiste mais je
dois dire qu'à l'ouest de la réalité de
la théorie à la réalité car en matière
de concurrence entre l'avion et le train
puisqu'il s'agit ici de favoriser le
train de la banque de france
ferroviaire dans la phrase les tgv
l'accès rapide régulier confortable un
capital et yal'autre france c'est celle
de l'excellent intermittente chaotique
avril et nous aurons besoin donc des
lignes aériennes
je ne parle pas des grandes villes
toulouse ou nice je parlais des petites
capitales régionales je parle d'âge est
monsieur le ministre je parle d'aurillac
monsieur le président al de brive de
castres dupuis de l'agneau et tout c to
c
ces villes sont desservis par des lignes
régionales
ces lignes régionales sont des lignes
déficitaires qui sommes en jouer par les
collectivités locales
les conseils généraux les lego de
l'agglo ou les
les communes donc si on supprime cet
abattement donc sur la taxe intérieure
sur l'athéisme
on va encore aggraver le déficit est
donc chargé encore plus de créativité
donc on vous perdez à ce nous sommes
donc concrètement demain c'est peut-être
du court terme mais pour nous pour
sortir de nos territoires
le court terme passe par les terrains
d'aviation et par l'avion donc nous ne
pourrons pas l'associer donc à cet
amendement et monsieur ruquier monsieur
savary est rappelé que dans le transport
aérien
le président sud ministre mes chers
collègues que le prix du carburant
devient de plus en plus lourd et ça a
été évoqué c'est quand même un mode de
transport tout à fait important qui se
démocratise de plus en plus plus de 35%
maintenant du coût de transport aérien
est générée par le prix du carburant
alors qu'il était encore à 25%
il ya très peu de temps je pense que
nous allons de plus en plus vers des
échanges à l'intérêt de notre pays ou à
l'extérieur de notre pays qui sont
ouverts à davantage de monde
il est important de démocratiser
l'ensemble des modes de transport dont
le transport aérien en tout cas ce sont
ces lignes la qui font vivre les
aéroports régionaux et qui amène un
certain nombre d'attractivité et
d'économie supérieure à ce que l'on
avait imaginé
je prendrai juste ans d'un exemple nous
avons un aéroport dans la marne
l'aéroport de vatry qu' un certain
nombre d'entre vous connaissent et nous
avons ouvert des lignes intérieures
paris vatry et marseille et vatry nice
et contrairement à ce que l'on peut
croire quand on fait l'analyse des
passagers il ya plus de passagers qui
viennent de nice et marseille vers la
champagne que de champenois qui vont
vers nice et marseille
comme quoi l'attractivité générés par
des échanges à des coûts raisonnables
permet de créer des activités
supplémentaires donc il est important
là aussi de ne pas alourdir le coût
c'est la raison pour laquelle je serais
personnellement opposé à ce type
d'amendements d'autant plus que monsieur
le ministre l'a bien dit l'avitaillement
des avions se fait facilement en dehors
de nos frontières à des endroits où le
prix du carburant est nettement plus
avantageux merci merci monsieur savard
et monsieur dassault
longueur
c'est le présent sans collègues
permettez moi de féliciter notre miss du
budget de la sagesse de sa réalisation
est à propositions qu'ils souhaitent à
fait raisonnable quand un avion va en
dehors de france je suis et pas si peu
un peu servant de la force du après eva
a peut-être assez loin du québec
qu'ailleurs est donc inutile d'appliquer
cette procédure pour tout le monde
voilà merci monsieur b je suis monsieur
dassault madame keller et merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais remercier notre
collègue d'avoir par son amendement
ouvert ce débat important
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
c'est la convention de chicago de
l'après guerre qui ne permet pas la
fiscalisation du gazole utilisé par les
avions élargissant d'ailleurs je crois
une réglementation en vigueur depuis le
moyen-âge et qui concerne le transport
maritime
c'est d'ailleurs ces deux secteurs là
qu'il s'agirait de traiter au niveau
international
si nous voulons progresser si l'europe a
décidé d'intégrer les transports aériens
dans les mécanismes des quotas carbone
ce qui est quand même une bonne nouvelle
et on voit que sa mise en oeuvre
d'ailleurs rencontre certaine résistance
je ne suis pas sûr cher françois marc
rapporteur que ce soit un sujet qui
relève des assises de l'environnement
parce que à un taux raisonnable
probablement progressive dans le temps
on pourrait certainement recueillir un
consensus politique très large sur cette
taxe mais par contre la question c'est
du le processus de renégociation de cet
accord mondial monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
éléments sur ce que le gouvernement
entend mettre en oeuvre pour transformer
en réalité ce qui est une une
proposition raisonnable mais de très
long terme je vous remercie
merci madame keller bien donc je suis
sur le 121
la commission a demandé le retrait et si
j'ai bien compris le gouvernement a
indiqué retrait défavorable bien alors
je vais mettre aux voix
un monsieur montech oui je me félicite
qu'un certain débat a été ouvert même si
c'est des débats qui dépasse largement
la moment et notamment le lien entre la
convention de chicago et le débat qui
est sûre effectivement la table des
négociations internationales autour de
ce qu'on appelle les bunkers taxe à la
fois pour le transport aérien et pour le
transport maritime nous ne sommes pas
ici dans ce cadre là puisque nous
parlons que des vols intérieurs
n'intégrant pas les vols de rafale je le
précise quand même mais à ce niveau là
c'est sinon ça augmenterait peut-être
effectivement les recettes mais je je je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nous avons quand
même à nous poser la question de savoir
si le transport aérien doit bénéficier
le fait d'un dumping fiscal notamment
par rapport au transport ferroviaire qui
aura besoin encore plus demain du
soutien de l'état pour la modernisation
des lignes et notamment des lignes hors
tgv donc je crois puisque on a parlé de
convictions ici que ma conviction et la
conviction du groupe écologiste c'est le
maintien
évidemment de cet amendement bien alors
ça ne change rien sur le fond un avis de
retrait de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement
je mets donc aux voix qui est pour et
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
bien il n'est pas adopté un article au 9
ha pardon le 120 toujours après
l'article 8 à un amendement numéro 120
qui est présentée par monsieur dantec
sarah shourd
sur sur le 120 je serai plus plus rapide
le débat est déjà lieu à l'assemblée
nationale c'est un amendement qui
s'inscrivent et je crois que dans dans
la droite ligne du débat de ce matin sur
la taxation exceptionnelle des bénéfices
des compagnies pétrolières en insistant
sur sur un point qui est que l'auto
consommation des compagnies mais n'est
pas taxé ce qui est ce qui est quand
même un très mauvais signal en termes de
process et ça rejoint là aussi le débat
sur la lutte contre l'effet de serre je
pense que taxer comme c'est le cas pour
les autres consommation de produits
pétroliers
cette auto consommation des raffineries
ray certainement dans le sens de
l'amélioration des process et de la
lutte contre l'effet de serre néanmoins
il est apparu qu'il y avait là
probablement une incompatibilité avec le
niveau européen donc je retire
l'amendement au nom de cette
incompatibilité même si je pense qu'il
était très peu de pédagogique d'insister
sur le fait que là il ya des
améliorations de process et des lutte
contre l'effet de serre important dans
cette auto consommation des raffineries
est donc retiré à l'article 9 je suis
saisi d'une demande de parole de madame
beaufils pour le groupe crc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
cet article est le premier d'une série
de plusieurs dispositions portant sur la
question de l'impôt sur les sociétés de
manière disent en général nous
approuvons la vidéo zoophile générale
qui anime ces articles tout en exprimant
de réflexion la première c'est que nous
n'avions pas vu de texte financier
comportant un volet aussi important et
aussi variés deux mesures concernant
l'impôt sur les sociétés depuis
longtemps
aussi il nous semble indispensable que
les textes à venir approfondissent
singulièrement la question la seconde
réflexion découle de la première cette
floraison législatives outre qu'elle est
bienvenu montre qu'il ya de quoi faire
dans le vaste champ de la fiscalité des
entreprises
les entreprises ont été au centre des
politiques du moins dix ans auspices
cale depuis plusieurs décennies
la croyance assez répandu voulait que
moins longs soumettait les circuits
productifs à l'imposition plus les
vertus d'une plus grande liberté
d'action conduire l économie tout
entière sur la voie de la croissance du
progrès du plein emploi le fameux
théorème de schmidt les profits
d'aujourd'hui sont les investissements
de demain et les emplois d'après demain
c'est largement appliquée en france
comme en europe pour un résultat dont
nous connaissons tous la teneur et dans
les salariés vivent les conséquences
pour la france 5 millions de chômeurs à
temps plus ou moins complets 3 millions
de salariés payés au smic
un salarié sur 10 3 millions de salariés
précaires une industrie représentant
aujourd'hui péniblement un sixième de
notre produit intérieur brut
70 milliards d'euros de déficit de notre
commerce extérieur et une croissance
atone
s'interrompant parfois aussi vite
qu'elle avait faiblement repris pour
l'europe une concurrence fiscale et
sociale exacerbée des millions de
chômeurs avec des taux atteignant 25 %
de la main-d'oeuvre en espagne dont 50%
chez les jeunes devenu un véritable
gruyère farsi d'exemptions et de
dérogation les plus diverses
la fiscalité des entreprises doit
clairement être revu et corrigé selon
certains économistes 178 milliards sont
affectés tous les ans à la réduction des
impôts et des cotisations sociales
prélevées au niveau de la production
donc de l'entreprise demain il est
évident que l'essentiel de la fraude
fiscale comme l'a montré le travail de
la commission d' enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale provient des entreprises et/ou
leur est destiné nous avons là du grain
à moudre des marges importantes de
réduction des déficits comme des moyens
à mobiliser pour financer les politiques
publiques percevoir mieux pour dépenser
utile voilà ce qui doit à notre avis
guider le travail de la nouvelle
majorité parlementaire et ses quelques
unes des propositions que nous formulons
par voie d'amendement dans la suite qui
va venir
merci merci mesdames beaufils
je suis le président de commission
finances je souhaitais dire quelques
mots à propos du calendrier de nos
délibérations
car je me livre
pardonnez-moi cs fonctions aux petits
calculs classiques du braquet de ce
qu'on appelle traditionnellement le
braquer ce matin c'était huit
amendements à l'heure cet après midi
c'est de l'ordre de 2
et sachant qu'il demeure 140 amendements
à examiner
il faut si je ne me trompe une vingtaine
d'heures de débats ce qui signifie que
en fonction de ce que nous allons
pouvoir faire cet après midi il faudra
peut-être sollicité de la conférence des
présidents l'ouverture de samedi car
demain vendredi ne suffirait pas au
rythme actuel
alors je me permets simplement de dire
cela pour l'information de tous ce n'est
pas autre chose que la pendule qui vous
parle bien merci monsieur le président
donc je suis saisi d'un amendement
numéro 112 à l'article nov qui est
présentée par monsieur dominati oui mais
chez président et au nom du groupe ump
je rejoins un peu madame keller pour
dire au président la commission des
finances que c'est surtout les débats à
l'intérieur de la majorité
présidentielle est dans l'absence un peu
de préparation je dirais de cette loi
rectificative que l'opposition observe
ce débat dans la majorité plurielle
alors en ce qui nous concerne cet
amendement est destiné à supprimer
l'article 9
monsieur le ministre parce que d'une
part nous constatons qu'il s'agit d'une
contribution exceptionnelle
un avancement de trésorerie des sociétés
et que cela altérera le budget 2013 au
profit du budget 2012 et à partir du
moment où n'ouvre dorion un
rétablissement à une lecture juste comme
vous dites des comptes eux c'était quand
même l'occasion de rétablir un mécanisme
qui il est vrai a eu lieu dans le passé
mais qui a tendance à s'amplifier
mais surtout c'est aussi une question de
principe et prendre la trésorerie des
entreprises pour enfants faire
bénéficier la trésorerie de l'état comme
c'est marqué dans le rapport c'est quand
même faire preuve d'un grand cynisme
dans la conjoncture économique présente
notamment vis-à-vis du monde de
l'entreprise
alors nous avons dénoncé
qu'effectivement c'était essentiellement
vole cible dans ce budget rectificatif
toutes les prestations prises pour rêver
je dirais d'efficacité des entreprises
et le rapporteur nous avait dit en
commission que c'était 42 % de l'effort
fiscal qui atteindrait les entreprises
mais l' aléa un cynisme aussi loin en
disant nous avons un besoin de
trésorerie pour l'état et nous allons le
prendre dans les grandes entreprises
parce que ça c'est fait
occasionnellement
vous êtes en train de
l'institutionnaliser c'est pour cela que
le groupe ump a déposé cet amendement
pour supprimer l'article 9 t au sur
collègue monsieur le rapporteur général
pour l'avis de la commission
oui il est favorable bien sûr je crois
que je vais peut être plus long c'est
une perte de recettes pour 2013 certes
mais il s'agit pas de prendre combien
dire nous coller de l'argent dans les
entreprises il s'agit d'une fiscalité il
s'agit d'une fiscalité qui existe et il
s'agit donc d'anticiper une recette
selon des modalités qui sont clairement
définis on prend pas d'argent avec je ne
sais quel outil nouveau il s'agit bien
des outils existants avec une
anticipation de recettes c'est une ville
en trésorerie et pour 2013
il ya une réforme de la fiscalité sur le
patrimoine sur l'impôt société et sur
les revenus qui est envisagé et je
trouve qu'on je pense qu'on trouvera les
dispositions nécessaires pour apporter
la recette
dont on aura besoin à ce moment là donc
je suis défavorable à cet amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur général sur
le ministre merci monsieur le président
le gouvernement est défavorable à votre
amendement monsieur le sénateur dominati
deux remarques si vous le permettez
d'abord il ne s'agit pas de la création
d'une recette celle ci était déjà prévu
prévue par la majorité précédente voté
par celle ci et il s'agissait à l'époque
et pour l'état de reprendre une avance
de trésorerie que précisément cet état
consent aux entreprises vous consentez
aux entreprises de plus de 250 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires il s'agit
en revanche d'une modification du
calendrier de perception de cette
recette pour des raisons qui n'échappe à
personne et que je ne cacherai
naturellement rien ni à votre sagacité
ni au sénat mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement émet un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance nous
reviendrons plus largement sur le détail
de l'examen de ce collectif budgétaire
dans notre édition de 22 heures
présentée ce soir par pierre henri
gergonne très belle journée à tous